okay next we got robin deangelo um she's
the nutty hack who wrote
white fragility and then she wrote
another book recently that
i guess nobody read um i don't think
anyone's actually read white white
fragility either by the way
it sold a lot of copies i don't i think
probably 10 people have read it
but it sold a lot of copies um the other
book didn't even sell any copies
she was on some kind of show or podcast
uh recently i don't even know what show
this is doesn't matter
and this is the conversation that
occurred listen to this
talk to me about when you first realized
you were white
and whiteness yeah talk to me about that
um
i i it was a very abstract sense i i
honestly believe i was about
um 34 years old i was college educated i
was a parent
um and someone handed me peggy
mcintosh's article
yeah and i read through that list
and i had an out of body experience i
could tell you where it was sitting
i i i i'm not ever going to forget that
moment where
all of a sudden i was like oh my god i'm
white
and i felt so loudly white that i
remember
being hesitant to go outside i didn't
want to go outside
because everybody could see that i was
white
well here's the thing robin we could see
it before you realized
we could see it all along
you have to laugh about it because
uh the other option is crying and i've
already made clear that men should not
cry
but we can laugh at how insane this
is but this is what this is this is this
is what people this is what
kids are being taught in school
as whiteness is it's like a disease
realizing that you're white i mean she
talks about it if you didn't have any
frame of reference
and you take out a couple of the words
here and there that she uses you would
think she was
recounting the time when she got the
test results back and found out that she
had
uh breast cancer or something she's
talking about it like it's a disease
because that's how she sees it
and that's what and that's what this is
what critical race theory brings it's
what kids in school are being taught
about themselves to hate themselves
and whiteness it's not just you know
it's this kind of
it's like this spiritual concept
it's apart from skin color but also it's
connected to your skin color
it's a it's a spiritual affliction that
is passed down
by your ancestors to you
uh does any does anything good happen
from that
i mean where does that go when you when
you raise
entire generations of people entire
races of people
to hate themselves and be self-loathing
[Music]
where does that head is there any
historical analog for that
for that working out well for society
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content